oh
oh god it's the tongue
it's the dog
no oh
okay one more time oh
my god so good i love the talk
you taste like mango
[Laughter]
that is pretty much the essence of free
yourself really yeah
that is it you could bottle it up into a
little intro of a show
for yourself for yourself to be yourself
that's it mariah winter thank you for
coming on the show
anytime it's hard to get us powerhouses
you know in one spot
but the [ __ ] powerhouse is exactly
powerhouse i love it
that's a
that's a new
exceptional descriptor for
you and for many of the other guests
that come on the show but you're the
only one that's
brave enough to write something like
that in your bio it's actually really
great
yeah of course i'm not i'm not too
attached to uh
titles like a content creator especially
an la musician
yeah holistic wellness bio feedback yeah
blockchain expert yeah there's
a lot of that and spiritual leader
mm-hmm
yeah exactly it takes the individual
individuality out of it and kind of just
groups you with the
the collective consciousness a little
bit yeah and it also
establishes you as a [ __ ] powerhouse
that's what i'm saying
yeah which is great because ultimately
you get to
as you free yourself you get to decide
how to play
how to be and like if we want to do some
like weird like
like like some weird [ __ ] like that you
know
then you can we can yeah because we're
free
mm-hmm ultimately yeah yeah
and we don't fit into straight jackets
no and that's
it's a shame that other people do you
know i mean too bad doctors don't come
on your show and then want
you to lick their face in the in the
shot yeah
exactly that's true i mean
it's that's just how that they want to
be perceived so
yeah there's
it's so interesting contrasting
the essence of how we're like opening
this show
right now with the essence of maybe
some of the other guests that we have on
the show that are very very
surgically precise about their image and
their political correctness
and their potential clientele
and all this type of stuff exactly it's
an interesting contrast
actually the show we talked about this
little before we started but it
definitely reminds me of
of maya or midas who's lyanna's daughter
who was on our show who
is you know a nine-year-old and she was
teaching us how to not be a boring
grown-up and it has a lot to do with
just being free
being at play and being imaginative
spontaneous creative like that and not
being
in a straight jacket yeah and i think
the more that you are
doing being free and just being yourself
you know like all the clients that
you're afraid that are going to fall
away because of that well they're
probably
not aligned with you anyway you know
so you're only bringing in that which is
more yourself
by being yourself and it liberates you
to have that
while it liberates other people to do
the same
you know so it's uh yeah
all that being scared of like oh from
one way or another
you know because i have to be perceived
this way in order to get these jobs or
to get
this then you're not letting yourself
receive the blessings that are maybe
meant for you that you're too tied to
your idea of what you think it should be
instead of just letting you be you to
then get the things that you
are for you actually not what you think
is for you
yeah yeah you're gonna attract
your soul essence when you
free yourself and when you constrain
yourself you're gonna
attract some sort of masked
societal exactly essence
there's almost a level of propaganda
that exists
in the matrix machinery that sort of
keeps people masked and then
it makes it so that even people that
sort of break free from
the economic machinery to be more of
themselves
still in the cases of needing to
earn money from people that are in those
sort of costumed
masks makes them still have to play that
game
yeah so part of the future architectures
of a more enlightened society appear to
be
where there are no masks that it's only
just your own unique essence and that's
it and there's no shame there's no guilt
there's no lower egoic
vibrations of existence of consciousness
of human development there's none of
those levels
yeah yeah
mariah you're really unique in that
sense
and that's why i think the episode we
decided to just go with free yourself
and let's start on it from a perspective
on consciousness
and we'll work our way to all these
other topics that we have
and we also have also some of
mariah's super
quirky videos and her links are in the
bio below to both her youtube
as well as her instagram having fun on
both guys
just so you know that's right that's
right
so so let's start it off with
why you think reality exists why does
reality exist
i think reality exists for experience
and experiencing
not just like for ourselves but for
the collective of everybody it's just
simply put
you know and then through that
experience begin to become
more i guess like aligned or something
would that be
yeah yeah um but basically it would just
be for
the experience yes
that's a great way to put it reality
exists for the experience
and the
sort of perennial spiritual mystic
traditions would say something like
we are eternal or we are infinite so
meaning
before this and after this there is no
before and after but
if you view it that way what happens is
that you realize that we have been
experiencing and we will continue
experiencing because there can be no end
to experience
that's pretty much the essence of the
tradition
you can't finish exploring all the
possible states of experience
which is probably why there's eight
billion of us and that's just on one
in one creation yeah it's not even
taking into account
any of the other creations or any of the
other
vehicles in those creations that
sentience emerges itself
and then begins to reflect on its own
being mm-hmm
yeah and when you begin viewing it that
way it sort of makes things
more playful and more definitely
yeah yeah it takes a lot of the
heaviness out of it you know i think
getting too
heavy on it what it is it takes away
from the experience
of the fact that you're in reality you
know and it's like yes that's there to
contemplate it's there to think about
but to take it too seriously and
i think is takes away from the whole
point of
being here anyway and it's almost as
though there's a balance between
needing to ask yourself that most first
principled question just so that you can
gain a better understanding of the true
nature of what we
really are and then as you sort of
uncover that
simultaneously express yourself in it
exactly yeah don't get trapped yeah
and not expressing yourself yeah yeah
and just allow yourself
to create in this space you know for
others to then experience that creation
too
exactly because that's what all of this
is
everything around us is just the
expression of other conscious agents
that have come before us and that have
made this [ __ ]
and now we're experiencing it and so you
can do
literally the same thing for kids that
are like 10 years old right now
mm-hmm exactly build something for them
to use
yeah and experience so that's where the
whole idea and imagination space comes
in
the more you free yourself the more you
get to express yourself
the less you free yourself the more
you're in a straight jacket
and your imaginations and a straight
jacket your creativity's in a
straitjacket
it doesn't allow for
the creative space that is
needed to create like the life you want
and not even just like you want
but just something that's
i find it's best when the creative part
of sharing it
you know with everybody else i think
that that's when
yeah yeah it's really rich because then
you get to
experience how somebody else experiences
what you created
exactly that's so dope like when people
leave comments on the videos
that we make and stuff like that it's
that's really fun and when people use
products
you know some of these products have you
know especially
software's there's a billion people
using some of the software's around the
planet you know some of the social
networks and stuff like that and so
tesla cars tesla cars and all these
different types of things and that's
hardware and that's
that's a that's an even harder game to
play software is a lot more scalable and
so if you
sort of like
build something that a billion people
gain value from
that's a pretty fun thing to do yeah
exactly a fun thing to do especially
when it brings
good value you know and you really hone
in on like
one of the most important metaphysical
concepts around these
soul vehicles and these conscious agents
that are part of that oceanic oneness
but on these individual
agents that oceanic non-duality but in
these individual agents
is the word decipher you have to
decipher between
what is good and what is bad to decipher
everything being double edged when you
get the smartphone you get the
technology you have to know
when is it yeah what is good what is bad
there
how can you use it to create and
maximize
bringing value to people versus just get
sucked into
a cycle that is actually harmful to your
mental health and well-being
yeah and i think that's where you said
like you know there's that balance of
you know asking kind of what is reality
and kind of defining that for yourself
and then that's when you can really
bring value to whatever you're creating
you know yes so you know the further you
go deeper within
you can take people there with you yes
they can only go
as far perfect yeah deep as you've gone
perfect and then whatever you make that
comes from that
you know that adds you can then have a
better justification of like is this
good is this bad
you know and like perfect what type of
value you're bringing it's perfect
perfect perfect way to put it
it's as though if we juxtapose it the
way that we usually do is
self-realization is when you understand
the unity of all being in existence the
non-duality the oceanic-ness and the
self-actualization is
the exterior artistic expression of your
unique contribution to the world
and what most people get stuck doing is
they get stuck in the ritualistic
self-help style of achieving some sort
of
business in the world and then what
happens is then they were oh well how do
i know what's good and bad how do i know
what morality is
oh like
what the reason why you don't know [ __ ]
about morality and you're having
any issues with it at all is because you
haven't went inward first
when you go inward that's when you
realize the unity of all being in
existence that oceanicness that
non-dualness and when you get to that
point
that's when you basically realize the
self
in the other and then you're always in
perpetual
service to other you're always
creating from a place of the highest
morality it never becomes an issue
i'm glad you brought that up yeah and
there's there's almost like when you do
start on the path
of the outward growth and you know like
you get so far and then you have to go
back in
there's always that reconstruction you
have to rebuild your foundation
you know and if you just start almost
with going deeper without having built
much anyway you won't have to have that
reconstruction refoundation moment
you know and so it's almost
great i think it's great that you know i
feel like i had
almost that moment before i've built
anything like astronomically big
yeah so you did yeah yeah
actually let's uh that's a really good
segue to it
maybe let's jump to that and then if
if the other first story comes up at
some point as well we'll hit it but
let's go to this
most recent yeah exploration of
you know how you figured out how to sort
of many people find themselves in some
sort of like perpetual suffering trap of
some sort
including myself and i have yet to
transcend
all of my
egoic tendencies and self-dealing habits
and
advices and of course
you can't click unsubscribe fast enough
you know
yeah that's like yeah in essence what it
would and
you have to work at clicking unfollow
and unsubscribe on all these
habits and patterns and so walk us
through
yours and then how you overcame that
well my i guess with uh this last year
um i mean mine kind of started with a
bad relationship
and severely under judging how
hard that was affecting me which is very
easy to do when you want something to be
a certain way and be good and then it's
not actually good
and also my habits were pretty awful as
well
um and it was something i was pretty
aware of you know knowing that okay this
relationship's awful these habits are
awful um but then
never fully stepping into my power to be
able to
kind of like get rid get things away and
um it kind of just started and even with
me like starting to now
become more myself like out in the open
and be unapologetically me
that was kind of the big turning point
was um sorry
was i was um needing
i guess i was just feeling like i really
really needed to express that and
i love that yeah yeah and it's like
screaming
it was screaming yeah and it was in
there it's no longer a knock anymore
it's like beating the door down with one
of those
like yeah door uh
yeah yeah it's like the the jaws of life
or some [ __ ] we're coming in
yeah yeah there you go and just like
trying to rip me out of like this busted
car
and like because you know when it came
at a weird time like you feel like
you're almost gonna have like these
moments of
i want to like just desperately be
myself whatever that may be
you feel like that's gonna come at like
a time when you're more like at peace or
whatever mine just came when i was like
in a very
just trash moment of my which happens
sometimes in people's trajectories it's
like the sludge hammer instead of the
feather
yeah exactly and then it turns like once
it hits it turns into this weird feather
but you know and then i started to kind
of like explore my own youtube channel
which then
got me into being like okay and
you know that this my content on there
is uh
it's just me you know at its essence it
started in like this booty workout phase
which yes i'm into
love that stuff uh but then i realized
i'm like i don't want to be a fitness
expert
like i enjoy working out but let's not
go there then i was kind of
rattling about like things i was dealing
with and like booty diaries
there's that whole thing but then i was
look at these booty diaries
yeah but then um i was like you know
all of these would just be practicing
kind of to get to now where it's more
like okay i want to
bring more value to that as in like let
me go to the things that like are
interesting to me and i have
like also i have a music video and photo
background
you know sort of like to not use my
skills to then enhance my videos didn't
make much sense
you know like i was like okay i'm
filming all this in my laptop
one of my good friends got me a new
camera so i was like okay this is great
now we can really like amp up this
production value
and then i can start implementing like
all these skills that i have into doing
oh yeah then we have the vaginal
microbiome that's that's a real me
moment right there guys
but um yeah i mean and i guess somebody
could look at this youtube channel and
say like okay whatever you just have a
youtube channel it's like a kind of like
a bunch of girly stuff whatever
but for me it's like that's
all this was created authentically you
know something for me to share
as something for me to just practice
like it might not be exactly what i want
to share yet but i'm trying to figure it
out you know and i'm trying to
trying on different things trying out
different
ways of i don't know like how myself
could look
but it's also allowed me to just now
when i walk into spaces and meet people
you know to really own that because like
this is on the internet like anybody
could see this yeah
so just knowing that it's like okay can
you can you go back to this
pendulum swing because it's so
interesting
where what were the emotions because
this is a huge pendulum swing
oh this is yeah yeah this is this is
like the
most open this is like literally we
introduced the show with
with like yeah yeah
that's like the complete opposite side
of this pendulum
of where you were yeah what were the
emotions that you were feeling
on that side and then the i know you
said that it was like a pressure cooker
basically
that shattered you through yeah walk us
through that uh i'd say the biggest
emotion that had the biggest driving
force behind it was self-betrayal
a thousand percent self-betrayal because
there was so much and the pain from that
i believe
is almost like the worst pain that you
could have you know if somebody betrays
you
that hurts but like when you're
betraying yourself
that is its own type of grief that i
just
wish upon nobody just because like
that's so almost controllable
and for me i was that's where like
wanting to be me because it's like okay
i'm just betraying myself i'm knowing
that this is
ultimately terrible for me i'm not
speaking up for my own needs i'm not
speaking up for
you know things that are making me
uncomfortable and i'm not speaking up
for just
anything you know so yeah
holy [ __ ] yeah so when you're having all
that
in and it's busting out you know it's
like
it's got to come out but self betrayal
is
just hands down that feeling a thousand
percent
so you know
you you literally know you knew that
there was
that separation between those two
feelings of
you knew what you needed to do
in order to make yourself feel that you
weren't betraying yourself
but that you weren't voicing your those
needs
and that you weren't getting out of the
perverse situations that you were in
yeah but you knew what you needed to do
but you still were going against that
yeah perpetually yeah that is that
sounds yeah that sounds
miserable [ __ ] it is yeah and
going through that you know there's like
i was trying to overcompensate to do the
one big thing i needed to do
by just doing i was like okay if i can
just be me in all these other areas and
like you know speak up for myself and
all these other things
maybe that thing will just take care of
itself but you know
so it's like but that won't take
care of itself yeah like it still is
there so
um ultimately i had to meaning the
relationship yeah exactly so it was like
okay this
this has to end um but
i was still trying to do all these other
things to avoid that to be like okay
well
you know i'm doing me more in this area
and i'm speaking up for myself in this
way and i'm doing this but that still
doesn't take care of the fact but it did
help to then make that decision though
and then did you end up like what were
some of those like
pivotal how did you sum up the courage
to make the pivotal cut
in your life there was i mean there was
just some hurtful moments that had like
all snowballed and it got to a point
where it's like okay this is a lot but
also i am i just kind of became
since i was doing things that were more
myself and getting into my own health
and my own wellness and i was getting
around a new group of people
yeah it was kind of giving me more of
like a okay
i have my own i i guess i'm identifying
myself
more to be able to be a bit more like
this is definitely not
yeah yeah damn there are likely a lot of
people
that are undergoing some sort of like
codependency
oh of course yeah in a relationship
where they almost
feel like it's like a half meeting a
half rather than two holes
of course and so like when there is sort
of this feeling of a half meeting a half
that
the number one fear is that aloneness
yeah
yeah and yeah yeah go ahead it's funny
because
you know you get so afraid like all
these thoughts are like
what if they get with somebody what if
they don't what if like you know you
have all these different
things of like these freak out moments
that aren't even happening yet
and then it ends and you kind of get a
little bit past that then you're like i
was scared of this the whole time
like i feel actually yeah i feel like a
huge
weight has been taken away from me you
know it's like something i don't
think about anymore it's not something
i'd like have to feel like okay i need
to do this i need to do this and then
keep putting it off
it's like well that's a big thing off my
to-do let you know and it just feels
so free and it's
but to get to that point it's not as
easy as it sounds you know it's not like
yeah just go you know
it's yeah yeah it's a pressure cooker
sledgehammer
yeah and i mean if you're dealing with
like a self betrayal within that of like
wanting more from it but you're not
getting more
or whatever i feel like that pain is way
worse than grieving
the loss of a relationship you know
it's just like yeah it is totally
yeah that's definitely a layer a level
maybe even two or more um self-betrayal
probably ranks in the worst
and uh grieving relationships like you
get over that [ __ ]
yeah exactly yeah you get over that [ __ ]
but
to you don't get over self betrayal
if you get stuck there um
that's where people talk about their
number one regret
in life being that they betrayed
their own divine path yeah that's some
[ __ ] you do not want to end up in
that position no
because that's like one of the worst and
it it takes the form in like so many
different things and relationships is
only one of those forms the economic
machinery is another one of those forms
if you get those golden handcuffs out of
company and you stay there yeah
all these different things it's also you
know it could be drugs it could be
drinking it could be any type of
substance whatever that you just feel
like you know you shouldn't do but you
keep doing it anyway it's
any of those things you know and like
some things hurt more than others some
things feel more of a burden than others
than that but
that's ultimately like you just want to
be the person who looks in the mirror at
you and says like
you know this is the person that will
not betray me on earth is this person
yeah in the mirror and exactly yeah
and that's sort of basically the
the in a sense the first step in many
ways is something like
you know your own patterns right you
know yourself
first and you have to know your own
patterns and then you have to love
yourself and accept yourself
yeah that's exactly
and then and then you can get to
elevated states of consciousness but you
really have to accept yourself because
you're gonna be a
you're gonna have a lot of things that
when you look in that mirror that are
difficult to accept which
is a classical process like diamonds
form under intense temperature and
pressure
welcome to being human exactly yeah
yeah um i mean the lotus flower grows
out of muddy waters
ah that's another one yeah
yeah i mean pain and all of that it's
not even so much of a
you know it's to me i feel like it's
just an indicator
and it's like a point in a different
direction usually
you know it's like okay this is where
we're going this is where we're starting
but from here then there's always the
rising afterwards
you know so it's like pain to power yeah
trauma to treasure mm-hmm
exactly and you know earlier this year
when i was even in those moments
of just like just pain pain pain i just
always knew it was like okay
the rising part's happening and the
longer you live you see this pattern
happen over and over over and over again
so you just like the faith just is there
of like okay i know this is gonna be
better
when is that gonna you know when is it
gonna be you don't exactly
you just don't know you know and even if
you do do one thing to be like okay i
got rid of that you still have to deal
with like a
semi-grieving process of like you know
losing whatever habit or whatever it
might be
you know that's keeping you that you
were betraying yourself with but then
you have your rising afterwards and that
transformation yeah
yeah it's really beautiful and i love
how you call it a pattern that you
become wise and see
and if we can get young especially gen z
gen alpha to understand this pattern at
younger ages especially we can send them
into like versus
immersive virtual realities
where we teach a pedagogy that is
around things like these patterns of
wisdom
they can get that pattern of wisdom at a
younger age and they can
they can skip a lot of the massive downs
in the roller coaster
they're still going to have downs but
that
if only you had you teaching yourself
when
you were 18 like you had yourself a 28
as in
mentor to yourself at 18 right same
thing with me with all of us
right we would love that [ __ ] we would
be like passing each other like dude
like check out all these wisdoms like
exactly that's hacked that script
there was there was a actually it's
funny you mentioned that i was like
last year i was like i want to write
this book called foresight where it's
not even about having like you know like
like just for literal younger people to
have
foresight about their life you know and
that
that can only be like received by
whoever wants to hear it and whoever
actually wants to follow that and like
not saying that whatever i would say
would be
but i just think that the idea of that
is really interesting you know like yeah
it's a great idea
have you considered putting maybe your
like foresight lessons that you would
want to pass along into some sort of
like a
like in high level perception we use
like a 10 chapter framework right so if
you like put up like a 10 chapter
lattice work
like you could hang your concepts in
that and sort of organize them and move
them around visualize them
because that's a really good exercise
yeah and it can help you
nail your core values and core concepts
and then potentially more easily share
them with the world
on especially your youtube and and
instagram
and yeah that's sort of what we do on
the programs we try and like draw this
out
of people because this sounds dope like
i love your idea of foresight
but like that might be your january
project that you were talking
about mm-hmm exactly yeah no that would
be
that honestly sounds great the because
i've had
without nailing in you know exactly like
which
values and which things i'd want to
focus on but that would be perfect
having the
different moving around and yeah exactly
it's hella dynamic like
this um right now i'm playing around
with
the calling this like the diamond
framework or the diamond method and this
just
goes something like a 10 chapter lattice
work like every human has their own
unique
north star right and own unique self
realizations as well
and so you follow somewhat you can pick
five or six or seven
chapters it can be complete whatever
number you want 10 is cool
it's it's a order of magnitude it's it's
cool it's power of 10
and there's something unique about sort
of being able to dynamically adjust that
throughout your life like here you are
you're 28 i'm 28 we have our little 10
chapter frameworks
but in a year we might move chapter
seven to where chapter five is and we
might
put chapter five and embed it in chapter
four and then sort of like
cons like synthesize those together into
one and maybe change the name of it or
something right
exactly and like to sort of not be
inflexibly stationary and static
is something really important and so it
sort of enables
you to like in this like diamond
framework idea
it's like it's like a perpetual lifelong
lattice work that you hold and organize
and like yours could literally be called
foresight and like
that's a really dope one and it could be
something that
you've sort of aimed to funnel
young people to the different chapters
of foresight that you have
because like one of the patterns that
you talk about is that trauma to
treasure
archetype mm-hmm it's common in every
single person
everybody has for some of them yeah
and everybody knows that it
especially on the other end that it's
going to be some sort of like a
repeating pattern like what you're
saying
but in the middle of it when you haven't
identified the pattern
you think it's the end of the [ __ ]
world yeah because you're stuck in that
perspective of suffering
and actually the passion of meditation i
think liberated me
most yes from that i i agree
anapana observing respiration
basically not being reactive but
creating that pause
and then it just liberates you from vast
majority of suffering
yeah i agree there's i mean i can also
attest to like when i was younger and
then not really having
the self-awareness of you know my
situations and what i was a part of
i wouldn't have been able to be like oh
this feeling is self-betrayal like
i'm self-betraying myself you know it'd
just be like
yeah this sucks and just kind of you
know so it takes even noticing
like knowing what that is and how that
feels and
so subtle yeah it's and there's exactly
there's subtleties in that and
everybody's so out of touch
i mean i myself am just starting to get
not just but like we're all like getting
more and more in touch with
our feelings and what they mean and
where they point us and what he's trying
to tell us
it's an emotional guidance system yeah
totally
towards union yoga
sanskrit for union hypnosis
is another way to put it like the greeks
say union union with what
with god what the [ __ ]
else would you be getting in union with
exactly with source with infinity
that's what you're [ __ ] getting in
union with exactly
you're gonna have an emotional guidance
system that's constantly telling you
throughout your entire life
like get out of that little tiny
perspective of suffering and ego
and rocky yourself up to the divine
[ __ ] god that you are
exactly yeah that's the the new thing
i'm trying to focus on because before it
was just like you know be nice to
yourself and blah blah blah now it's
like you are powerful
yeah oh yeah that's the new one
yeah we got out of like you know the
little suffering phase of just like okay
you know like be nice to yourself
self-compassion like you know you got to
focus on different things but right now
that i feel more free it's like okay i
am powerful
you know it's like i am a part of this
bigger conscious of this creative
space and that's something we all have
you know that's just not me
and that's everybody you know and
anybody who's hearing that and is like
oh i am powerful that's them talking to
them
really you know it's like that's
something that i really want to begin to
harness though and just see
like in what ways also helps increase
myself to like you know to further
strengthen that belief
and also like to live in that
fully yeah so what would it look like
to express
yourself powerfully
in 2021 for me
i would say it's kind of it's trying to
do i guess what i have been trying to do
these last few months is just like
unapologetic
unapologetically you know be
myself and want the things that i want
without feeling like it's taking up too
much space
or without feeling like it's asking too
much or asking too little
but realize that like if you do want
these things you know you're
you have the power to have them and
there's there's no
reason why you shouldn't you know yeah
yeah
and it's no it's not wrong of you to
want these bigger things
like that's that's a great thing you do
you know it seems as though that
the concept nunchi or emotional
intelligence plays a massive role in
this process you have to
be a ninja or a wizard in your
communication skills navigation
of the psyche in order to be able to
do this process in a harmonic
way exactly and so then
there's a there's sort of like a
a workout regimen that has to happen and
a lot of that includes like in a sense
like
trying and falling on your face yeah and
then
that's part of the process yeah that's
literally just life and like process and
luckily being
you know somebody who comes from a
creative background of like photos
videos and just seeing that like you
have to take a
[ __ ] ton of awful photos before you
start taking really good ones and you
have to take
so many you have to make so many bad
videos before you start making good ones
to then know that like starting
on kind of like a youtube thing or
whatever it might be you know it's like
i'm gonna have to make a lot of
whatever type videos and you know like
hit and miss and then try to get myself
to get what i mean that's fine but like
and before it was you know i want to
get all this done just to get the good
thing but now i legitimately enjoy the
process of making these things
and that's where it also just begins to
flourish because when you enjoy it
you know that translates through yes
yeah
and other people can feel that and
you're just doing it purely for you
liking it you're not doing it for
this reason of like it's going to get me
farther it's going to get me more this
more that
it's like no i'm like enriches my soul
like
yeah yeah yeah and like
that there's also a subtlety in that
because you know i do love photos and
videos but i didn't
the reason i was doing it before when i
was doing a lot of like
hip-hop videos and stuff it was because
like oh this is cool and like other
people think i'm cool
if i do these hip-hop videos you know
what i mean
yeah and not realizing that maybe i
really like photo and videos because i
actually just want to be a dork on
youtube
boom yeah so that's it yeah
so like maybe all those skills just
equaled up to that
and before like last year it'd be like
that's literally insane but now it's
like nah that sounds way cool like i'm
down with that and i
so much more enjoy the process i so much
more enjoy the people i'm around now and
the communities i have
just based on that simple decision and
letting that
kind of take over but also knowing that
it's not
for like popularity you know it's just
literally like that's just what i like
yeah dan eldon says the journey is the
destination
exactly yeah and that knowledge
anchored in your body every moment and
living from that literally your
moment-to-moment artistic expression of
yourself
as a sentient agent in this reality
is the whole point of it yeah so if you
can anchor yourself
in that presence that power of now
that is so rich but it's also
simultaneously
balanced with some sort of like an
intuitive knowing of
like oh well you know why la
right why am i here at the same time
because that way you're also doing
some sort of a sort of a deeper inquiry
so it's not
hyper hyper hyper um
now to that extent because you have to
enable yourself to have some sort of a
future
authoring as well at the same time
curious about this because this is
really true it's very similar with me
looking back you know producing
700 plus of these in three years it's
hilarious we talked about this before we
started just looking back at the journey
and how
fun it is to sort of look back and poke
fun at how shitty we were at what we
were doing
a couple years ago versus now and
sort of also in a sense
enjoying the fact that one of the
coolest parts probably of being
on the internet and turning yourself
on that side of the spent on the
pendulum is that now
you get to create a log a library for
yourself
and for your like family and friends and
for
other people around the world that are
watching that are getting value from
what you're making
it's definitely one of the coolest
aspects to being a content creator
and i would say that whatever you end up
doing in 2021
in terms of whether it be five of these
little
concepts in foresight or however many
you end up doing
it seems as though every single one of
these concepts
ends up becoming as you form it
and you kind of anchor it in that
foresight lattice
it sort of becomes part of you
at a much deeper level than when it
almost didn't have some sort of like a
name
or a spot in that lattice work so it's
like it's
really important that's why words are so
important because they create
some sort of a you know a logos an
expression in the reality that we can
then label
that even if it's like an imaginative
concept that if we don't haven't labeled
our core values it's much less likely
that we actually know what they
are so would you then
probably say that
within that sort of
framework let's say of like if you were
to pick like your top
favorite concept that you're looking at
for you know january and 2021
what are you thinking for like your top
favorite expression of yourself
top favorite expression of myself um
wow
i just want i mean my mind just goes
into straight into like we'll just be
yourself
um because i'm just trying to own like
that whole bit but i guess if i was to
focus on like a value per se
um the value would have to be
i like the idea of i mean i've spoken
about this with you before this like the
how authentic self and how i think that
that's kind of like a broad
term you know for people to kind of
really and feel like they can
touch that and like know what that means
for them it's kind of like authentic
self like okay
but like i said like the creative self
and then the destructive self is a
better way of putting that
and i kind of just want to step more
into
the creative part of that
maybe the very fact of your deciphering
is a good concept to hang up in the
lattice work
like maybe creative versus destructive
self becomes one of the concepts that
you aim to help other people decipher
yeah yeah because i do like taking kind
of these you know like broad
things that you'll hear because i know
for me when i first started hearing
these different like concepts and terms
like you need to be
your authentic self and i'm like what
the [ __ ] does that even like
mean you know to somebody who just was
kind of not living authentically
thinking i was because you always think
you are when you're not
you know you always think you are being
like this enlightened person when you're
not you know it's kind of funny because
then like
it's always like later on you're like oh
no
so you know i kind of like to try to
dissect that and make it as
simple like those concepts that for me
when they sound like really cool
and like oh i'm definitely doing that
you know like i'm definitely being my
authentic self
to then be like once you really kind of
truly understand that
and you can actually give it a
description and you know give it a
simple
way of describing it i that's how i want
to break
that down you know is become so much
more in touch with those
values to them be able to like simply
break them down for other people that's
right
which i think is kind of what you do
with your yeah yeah you try to
understand reality
yeah to the biggest yeah that's
yeah that's that's definitely that's
definitely in essence what you know what
this
is with high level perception and and
sort of this is sort of the idea of what
it would look like for
somebody else to also create some sort
of like a visual
lattice work of concepts like creative
versus destructive self is really
beautiful
and it's a really good one and it's sort
of
it's really resonant with people and
it's actually quite in a sense
easy to explain because
and it's also the difficulty in it is
more about
getting people to have a personalized
understanding
of their moment-to-moment creative
versus destructive
patterns yeah of habit and then how can
you visualize that because
maybe it does you know maybe it does
sort of take
some of the like maybe it does sort of
take some take on some aspects sort of
like these where there's sort of a
a clear maybe there's more of a spectrum
right some sort of a nuanced like
spectrum between that yin and yang that
perennial sort of wisdom of two poles
that are dialectically opposed and
harmonically ascending
and so maybe there is that sort of
polarity
that is a creative self destructive self
spectrum in between
and it's up to each individual person to
begin sort of seeing that and
visualizing it but like
who's making that visual right now i
don't know
i don't know anybody making a creative
versus like destructive self-visual i
know
there's people like you know this is the
this is the very classic you know we've
been using this a lot on the show this
is david hawkins's levels of
consciousness
you know like this is a pretty decent
example of it but it's
but it's still maybe one level like
higher than what someone
could understand from something that's a
little bit more simplified
in terms of creative versus destructive
self but generally speaking the
destructive self is down there by shame
and guilt and fear
and then the the creative self is by
enlightenment
peace joy yes it's also
you know there's a whole process within
that of
when you are in like your destructive
self mode because i was definitely there
you know it's like i wouldn't even want
to admit to myself that i was
yes yes there and you would just kind of
turn on blinders to the parts of you
that
are like okay well you know i'm doing it
i'm doing this part good but i'm just
gonna ignore like the fact that you know
i'm you know even something simple like
working at a job i really really really
hate
yeah and you know it's like but
everything else i'm doing good but i
have to do that and it's like
there's things that you have to get
really upfront with yourself and be okay
with that
you know in order to step into like
just fully creative you know it's like
to your full creative self
because if not you're still kind of in
that middle like
and that's still kind of a destructive
place to be yeah
so it's like the deciphering and
discernment
of the patterns that
sort of service suffering versus service
well-being
and that's something that you know we
talk about on the program a lot
is that you sort of have this
this very
essence of your own life trajectory that
looks something like
you know all the way there on the right
you have heaven
and well-being being something that's in
your high signal to noise where
throughout your life trajectory you're
getting closer and closer your north
star
and on the low signal to noise is
something like hell and suffering
and every single one of these
bifurcations trifurcations
is on the tree of possibility and you
can go in any of these directions
based on something as simple as your
recognition that your free will
decision at any of these moments can
alter your life trajectory
and so you know mariah could have easily
not been where she's at today had she
by the way we just when we were talking
to jessica st michelle
on the show a couple weeks ago you know
she was in a very very very cancerous
end of her relationship as well and that
she and especially many other in this
case
women find themselves in situations
where
they have a
this deep intuitive understanding that i
need to get the [ __ ] out
but that it's sometimes like you said
self-deception where it's like
it's not pulling the trigger it's not
making the move it's not doing it maybe
there's some other way to make it work
maybe there's some other way to make it
maybe some other way to make it work
but ultimately the highest amounts
of fullest
expression especially of the
female leaders that we've had on the
program have come
a lot from sort of releasing themselves
from that stereotypical
archaic representation
of what like marriage and relationships
are where it's like a
woman that is in service to like the the
patriarch
of the family and stuff it's more like
there's usually like a silent suffering
that happens
and you know i and not just this can
also go for
men too but um definitely you know
there's usually like this silent
suffering or like you just
know deep within you that there's like
something
like this relationship it could not just
but
there's something better like this isn't
what love is like you know like this is
kind of what it's like but this
isn't like love could be so much deeper
for me you know and so much more honest
and so much more true
and i'm sitting here accepting
this and it really puts your ends with
yourself you know you're like how did i
get here why is it getting here like
it's
i didn't want this to go this way you
know like of course you didn't start the
relationship knowing that but
it's then taking your power
back almost you know it's like okay now
i'm not going to just accept that for me
you know and i'm not going i know that
there's like the
what i want is out there you know it's
just like i have to go and
accept that and
there's that that's not an easy process
you know that was
like a the back and forth that goes in
your head of
yeah yeah this is kind of sort of maybe
kind of what i want a little bit
ish but it's nothing close to like the
deep
like imagine like unimaginable love that
you know i imagine for myself it's like
that's a lot of the time women do
get kind of trapped in that little like
i i just i i just keep hearing the word
self betrayal go in my head of like you
know even
that comes with like you're always told
to be kind of like
pretty and just be you know small and
quiet in a way
and so that kind of enters into your
relationship you know it's like
yep um yep yeah and
to break free of that is
you're probably gonna have to go through
a few things to break free of it
but once as you do you know it feels
good like now it just feels good to know
that like i've and i've gone through
similar situations like the one i was
just in
before so you know it's not like that
was like my first time it's just like
fine it just got
it has to get beat out of you almost in
like a way
and then by that time you're like okay
now i just won't
that i won't accept that anymore you
know
it's like now if something comes in it's
like we can truly evaluate this
and you know we won't have to beat that
type of a process
and yeah it's yeah
and that that seems also like one of
those concepts
is that the more that you
get into a creative versus a destructive
pattern
of of life energy the more that you
become wiser to be able to share the
stories with other people
and put up the concepts as visuals and
yeah you're you're explaining it well i
think a good
sort of way for us to uh potentially
continue
um before we uh keep going on some of
the
convo let's play let's play
all right so let's see what what comes
what comes to energy right now
what comes to energy
well this is play that's that's
something
[Music]
wow
oh
[Music]
and you know that's the balance you got
to have you got to go from deep to
you know this whole oh oh it's back
it's back no it's not i can't do it i
can't
do it anymore
i can't do it anymore
that massive tongue giant is back
oh my god
okay your turn ready all right look at
me uh
where yeah keep going keep going there
it is
there's a rule as you kill me back yeah
you can't lick me back
that's not fair it's not fair it's not a
fact that's not fair that's not childish
enough
you got no rules right yeah no rules
yeah you gotta let you go full blown
express mode
wait what does it look like wait
okay wait put your but wait put your put
your
tongue
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh man
wait wait and that's where it gets
interesting another idea hold on hold on
now this could get real weird really
quick that's good
this just looks like wait let's switch
it okay you do it
okay you do it ready
other side oh did i get it yeah you got
it yeah you got it okay let me i'm gonna
um one moment i'm gonna just i'm gonna
just bend it no
i'm just gonna yeah just actually that
might be a good segue into one of the
topics that um
yeah oh yeah that we were talking about
uh in the kitchen
before this is an interesting topic
actually
yeah i like our i like our um
that was a nice nice that was a good
plate that was a good time for you guys
to go up and get chips
um that was intermission so if you need
a bathroom break i would suggest
rewinding and restarting it
yeah or even or even better
yes um practice doing something like
that
with your friends family yeah family
might be a little bit
yeah yeah just those yeah some older
consciousnesses
a little bit like okay i thought you
were an adult [ __ ] yeah
apparently you're still a kid and it's
like yeah you don't get it mom yeah
exactly
yeah exactly yeah so do it with your
friends yeah yeah maybe a co-worker
you can pull them in do it at work i i
suggest
i suggest while you're sitting there at
work your boss
in a meeting you're just like yeah
you just say hey you ever see my belly
button and i need to
lift up you ever see my belly button
look at my belly button
have you picked your lint hair before
and your boss is like [ __ ] get the [ __ ]
or if your boss is cool they're like oh
i do that all the time
and then you'll know you're at the right
company that's period that's how you
know you're at the right company
this is a good test it's a great litmus
test in the middle of a meeting
to do something wildly eccentric and if
there's like
mirror neuron action right away like
when your boss like
gets jiggy with you right away then then
you know yeah then you know
it's a great litmus test actually i
think we're inventing something right
now
i think so yeah
[Laughter]
actually we're not inventing anything
it's like what charlie chaplin and robin
williams and
exactly sasha baron cohen jim carrey
it's basically like
i need to know more females that are
like like hyper eccentric
in the space like this someone probably
knows let me know in your
in the comments below where the hyper
shout them out
shout them out shout them out yeah we
need them over here we do we need
yeah we do or the foreign people as well
like who i mean
i know sasha mancon's a little bit like
foreign as well but
like who who are the more
foreign also people foreign women
because it's interesting that
these aren't new things they're just
like the
they're the number one people that
usually get beat
out of civilization we'll get back to
the topic that was in the kitchen but
this is like the number one
consciousness that's beat the [ __ ] out
of civilization is like
the the digest the gesture
yeah right it's only accepted if it
is somebody like jim carrey like they
have to be
at that level for it to be okay almost
you know like if not then it's like he
also had to work his way up to that yeah
of course
yeah i think there was like he almost
got pulled like or in terms of like
i think ace ventura almost got pulled
and like if that didn't happen
and truman's show didn't happen right
and like
i think yeah we have to make more
content like that it's kind of like what
we did
a couple weeks ago we made a little like
video a couple weeks ago
we were really eccentric in it we didn't
end up like figuring out a way to like
publish that there will probably be
little pieces that we can spray sprinkle
through but
like we need to figure out how to find a
rhythm of
that like like we're balanced right now
because we just came from a wildly like
playful
like super hyper creative thing to like
now we're like back in some sort of
conversation again like it's a very
conversational format
but like how do you sprinkle in like
that
into conversation like yeah and like
into like conversation to where people
feel like okay this guy
or this girl knows how to like
really throw a wrench into existence
that is unique and fun
and and it's fun to be around
and it's a fun like archetype to try and
maximize because
the economic machinery definitely beats
the living [ __ ] out of it
yeah yeah and it's cool that you know
how to
play oh course yeah no that's that's the
one thing
i'll always know how to do that
it makes me upset that i guess upset
might be dramatic
but that people lose touch with that you
know it's like
that's just that's what keeps me going
you know or those moments like even just
with myself like i could just be walking
down the street and just like
have like a little jig or like just yeah
yeah exactly yeah and it's crazy to me
that people are out of touch with that
like that's essentially like when you're
little
that's all you do you know it's like
that's it that's your pure
just like self without all this stuff
downloaded into you yet that's just you
you know like and you've just lost
complete complete touch with that
and that's something like for me that's
always something i've been aware of as a
kid it's like i want to make sure that i
always stay in touch with
that part of myself that is childlike
and you know i also just had like
imaginary friends like crazy for
way too long as a kid and like loved it
like
and that for me i was like i just held
on to him for a long time i was like
people get rid of these like i think
they're great
do you remember them yeah i do as an
adult yeah i remember yeah
can you tell us about your imaginary
friends this is so interesting so i had
a gang
of friends and um one of them was this
so
my alter ego was um because i had like
an
altered ego imaginary self so the thing
is
i was in heaven with my mom this was my
story
and then i had to come back down to
earth to be
so and i had to like prove to be
reunited with her or whatever
but there's this gang of friends that i
have
and i would teach them things like how
to ride bikes or whatever but then i had
a best friend named pop who was like a
dog
human person and then there was this
imaginary clown named
colleen who was a guy that would try to
beat us at different like
activities or like like essentially our
arch enemy but our whole thing was to
try to like get back to heaven so i
could be reunited with my mom
which my mom's not dead she's alive but
yeah but that was the story
yeah and that was how your imaginary
friends would be kind of helping you in
a game
yeah like a hallucinated game to kind of
like keep you
imagination like stimulated and occupied
oh we just hang out and be like alright
i'm gonna bring the gang and then like
we'd all just go do stuff and then
sometimes colleen would pop in and be
like
all right i'm gonna like you know we're
gonna do a bike race or whatever
and yeah and i had them for a long time
like i remember
i don't remember what age i was but i
remember i was like in my trailer park
subdivision thing like
and i was teaching them how to ride a
bike which obviously that's pretty
obvious
because like you're teaching imaginary
people how to ride a bike and i just
remember
like these kids that i would hang out
with they yelled like you still have
imaginary friends because they saw me
doing that from down the way and i was
like
no and then i was like
man i have to get rid of these things
like
dang how old were you do you remember
how old that that last
i had to be like eight or nine
eight or nine yeah yeah interesting so
like i wonder if there's
a like a common psycho analysis of
the kind of like dumping of
imaginary friends and if it's around
sort of that
age and also what would happen
if we kind of kept
yeah them around like for example when
we talk about things like the higher
self versus the lower self and things
like that like
when we talk about sort of like the
devil on the shoulder and
you have an angel on another and like
the devil's trying to pull you into some
like
you know subscribe to some only fans
account like uh
type [ __ ] and then yeah one more time
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah that's how you guys do it
and then and then you have the angel the
higher self that's like
oh trying to like pull you up to your
highest goals and stuff
and like there's a very
very delicate interplay that happens
between that
and what i would say is imaginative
friends
and it appears as though
in many ways that the more that i
commune with my
quote imaginary friend of my higher self
the more that i actually live a life
that's of greater well-being
so there's actually very practical
pragmatic
beneficial reasons for me to potentially
keep a quote imaginary friend
that is helping me achieve
good things in my life so
i don't even know like this whole idea
of like
let's destroy imaginary friends for
children yeah sounds like
it's a dumb idea probably yeah and
sounds like
for maybe there's pathological ways to
be like no
i want only imaginary friends i don't
want any real friends like
okay there's going to be some
pathologies on one of these polls
yeah but like the other pathology is to
just have
wipe all of them out period and let
nobody keep any of them
so maybe we should be like figuring out
how to
like keep good imaginary friends yeah
aka like higher selves in a sense and
leverage those i've actually literally
never made that
comparison that's a fascinating one
between yeah beautiful imaginary friends
and like
adult like angel on the shoulder in a
sense yeah
yeah and like you know that's just kind
of where a form of play would come from
yes yeah and so and i feel like now that
being older you know it's like now when
i'm by myself it's like
okay if i'm cooking i can turn on music
and then like
dance and cook or whatever and like
that's fun but i don't know maybe
there's some imaginary friend aspect of
that
too you know and even just like kind of
talking to myself or saying whatever it
might be
yeah but yeah that all comes probably
from just
the imagination and the imaginary
friendness that i had as like a kid
are you familiar with bicameralism the
bicameral mind no
what is that yeah there's like this
julian james and this bicameralism the
bicameral minds fascinating it's like
this
dialectical interplay between
hemispheres
and also the dialectical interplay
between you and god
and so there's like a
in a sense it'd be like okay i am that
and i also realize that that is like the
highest possible morality but
i also recognize that i am here in this
physical incarnation
and that i want to behave at the highest
morality possible
so that's basically what this whole
angel on the shoulder thing is
is it's like okay this is going to
represent god and i also recognize that
i
am god our awareness we are source we
are that
but i also have this angel on my
shoulder that i'm constantly in a
dialectic with
and like i'm constantly in a state of
bicameralism
in a state of dialectic with different
conversational points within myself all
the time all the time i'm like
almost all the time i'm in like
if i have to like like just earlier
today i was like pumping out
like getting some content done and like
you know i'm literally walking myself
through the steps
and you can tell that it's like i'm i'm
like having a dialectic between what
appears to be a more like ordered and
logical thinking process
along with like a more creative abstract
process
where like the logical process is like
okay what's the next step and the
creative process is like okay we'll try
and make the thumbnail look like this
to make it look a little more creative
and the logical part like does that
process and then like
the creative part says okay well copy
and paste that exact one
over and then change the fonts change
them change the color of them
and like i'm literally talking to myself
while doing this process
sounds a lot like imaginary friends
exactly
yeah it totally does and maybe that's
how
like that helped me learn it to be
that like the creativeness that i do
have you know
like being more in touch like having the
imaginary friends for maybe what i
perceived as longer just like i like i
don't know the
natural age but like i just noticed all
my other friends didn't have imaginary
friends when i was still having them
and maybe because of that you know that
just enhances your creativity or like
coming up with fake
activities to do with fake people and
like you know or
maybe within like uh spiritism
yeah that's interesting like alan kardeq
and spiritism
so maybe if you really want to get
potentially supernatural we might
actually be communing with spirits
as imaginary friends which is kind of
interesting
yeah i would love to scientifically
methodologically try and probe things
like that like energetically and see
yeah yeah that would be really
interesting because one of my friends
moms who's like really into like
metaphysical things like she had
mentioned like imaginary friends are
you know super spiritual like beings
whether that be
and then me also it's funny to think
that like my whole thing was
i was this fallen angel who was trying
to get back to heaven or something and
like
there's like a spiritualness in that but
why did i come up with that narrative
when i was a kid
you know and like what made me then
like you know what i mean like that has
some spiritualness to it just within
that
so definitely yeah it's really
interesting
and like why do i have them all like not
like you know like a
like a soul mom that's up there that i'm
like craving or something because like
do you you're almost running uh
simulations
in life like in computer science we call
this
the model based reinforcement learning
you're basically doing things like
creating simulations it with your
imaginary friends
where you're basically competing it was
like colleen
colleen yeah right was like a guy
that was constantly being like maybe
like an evil person or something like
that
and you were in competition right yeah
this is very like computer science
driven concept as well because
if you're basically running simulations
where you as a kid are like
representing the good trying to ascend
to heaven to mom
right and like you have to beat the bad
yeah
you're basically running simulations for
yourself
of how to decipher right between that
good and bad like we were talking about
oh yeah so you're like practicing
discernment
subconsciously in an imaginative space
ah
yes so fascinating this this is a really
interesting
revelation in our conversation yeah
super fascinating actually yeah
it would be cool to see like a k like i
i don't know a lot of kids
like to find a kid that does have their
own imaginary friends you know in the
capacity that i did
you know and then just kind of observe
that
goings-on and happening you know and
just to see
like because i remember you know like
for me tell us about your imaginary
friends let's
create a catalog of who they are and
what they represent and like make a
psychoanalytic study
of this yeah yeah it's a good idea it's
a really good idea
yeah it's very scientifically driven i
like that it would be really interesting
just for somebody like me too who had
their own
imaginary friends to be like oh well
like what does what did that mean for me
you know
like i just know i had that experience
but i don't necessarily know
like 20 years later we are uncovering
what it meant exactly yeah instead of
like
knowing like when i am eight like maybe
i should know when i am
eight what's going on that would be
great yeah i think more enlightened
parents
would uncover that type of stuff
with their kids and we should sort of
make a culture that makes it easier like
you're indicating where
we have spaces for kids to sort of talk
about what
their imaginary friends are what they
mean to them what kind of games they
play with them
yeah create catalogs of this stuff
mm-hmm
yeah it would be really interesting
super interesting
it also reminds me of like genealogy as
well like we don't do much
like idea genealogy let alone like
familial
genealogy but like maybe we should have
some sort of a cataloging system of you
know imaginative figures
and it's like an anthropology
archaeology
process that would occur of the
imaginative space for kids
and i think that's a really interesting
idea is like
and maybe like some kids are
temperamentally not
having a tendency to create imaginary
friends and some are like
wildly imaginative like you and that
there's that spectrum in between and so
maybe for the kids that
have none in a sense maybe it's
could be beneficial to maybe introduce
them to some of the ideas but
and maybe for the kids that are wildly
imaginative maybe it's so
it's it's it's okay to say like hey
maybe like
playing at the park or at the beach or
whatever is probably a good idea too
[Laughter]
jimmy's in his room masturbating all day
[Laughter]
yeah right and a lot of guys have
imaginary words
no yeah yeah yeah the internet
the internet yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
[Laughter]
the logging of this is great yeah the
cataloging of this is very interesting
like if we
if you could go back right now
and almost have a pretty clear like
bottled up like accurate experience
right you
were talking about this metaphysically
at the beginning if you could bottle up
the experience
of what you had when you were like eight
with those imaginary friends and like
come back and like revisit it right now
that's kind of what psychoanalysis could
do
to um sort of have these types of like
experiential logs of what was actually
going on during that time for me as a
kid
because i don't remember you do though
i do very clearly you have the names you
have what you were doing what the
intention was
it was just very i mean it was just very
important to me
like i really loved those friends and i
really
had a good time with them so like for me
i'd
i would never lose touch with that
because i just valued that
time a lot you know and like
to me it's interesting that kids didn't
have that or a lot so even i just meet
adults now that like don't remember
their childhood that much and
yeah yeah i definitely remember that
child
like part of my life a lot because i
just remembered seeing adults and be
like you know it's not
fun like i should really enjoy this time
now because and i always thought that as
a kid i'm like i should really enjoy
this time now because being an adult
just doesn't seem like
a bunch of fun which like you know you
get older and you realize oh you can
still have fun you know it's just
and luckily if you still carry that
still childhood sense with you you will
um but i've always just really valued
that even as a kid
and so like those memories and
experiences like resonate really well
with me because it's like
that was just great good moments in life
you know
yeah yeah the retention of the childlike
essence into adulthood is what pablo
picasso and so many other great
geniuses have talked about and
ultimately when you do that
you're going to end up being a lot more
creative you're going to end up being a
lot more
playful a lot more peaceful a lot more
blissful and a lot less in a straight
jacket
which is not free at all and
the whole episode is about freeing
yourself
and that all of these different ways
that we've been unpacking it
i think this one that we got to so
fascinating and it has such a deep
rooting
also with the way that
reinforcement learning agents in
computer science learn
and it's so interesting because we are
like that in so many ways as
humans with modeling and running
simulations
and then choosing the learning and
choosing the best
possible outcomes like decipherment
deciphering
discernment and imaginary friends
and especially like these youthful sort
of
potential battles that we undergo to
figure out morality is just that's
ridiculously
interesting in that it would be great to
log that
and it would be great to potentially
especially as we enter into that virtual
reality pedagogy that we were talking
about it'd be great to sort of
like what would happen to kids when
they're
undergoing exploring self-realization
and self-actualization of what the true
nature
of the unity of all being in existence
is that non-duality
when they undergo that
and then they undergo also the
discernment between
what is something that
is malevolent or tyrannical or
oppressive or violent
or self-deceitful all these different
scenarios compared to what is benevolent
what is flourishing what is prosperous
what is well-being
and like literally going through that
process in that
virtual reality pedagogy it's just like
that simulation
it's just like the imaginary friends
thing
yeah it's almost like i was doing that
like that my own version
like you said like the simulation like
my doing my own vr experience just
without
vr like yes yeah i was
doing that with my friends you know and
by trying to be like
which is kind of i've never thought of
it that way before
yeah yeah i'm really impressed that we
came up with some like
i'm impressed but i'm not surprised
because we constantly do these
like fascinating metaphysical
revelations of what appeared to be
something that is just something mundane
like imaginary friends like you would be
surprised
i would probably bet 95 maybe more
percent of people
would breeze past imaginary friends like
it's absolutely nothing
it's like oh yeah that's some [ __ ] that
happens in kids good go bye
but when you sort of create like
interesting dialectic and space to
unpack and you create analogies to
connect
concepts to it as well
man you can get to some interesting
places
really interesting
yes it's time for another play session
yeah i think it's uh
[Music]
oh look at that little booty bit
hey hey a little bit of that oh
pack it up back it up oh that's a new
camera angle for y'all
what's good what's good what's good
this is what enlightenment looks like
this is what enlightenment looks like
[Music]
oh he's gonna come up from the middle oh
one surprise is you're about to get
if you uh if you know anything about uh
if you're anything if you know anything
about mariah's channel
you might get a little surprise if she's
kind enough she might show us how to
twerk on the program oh yeah
that's a whole nother yeah yeah that's
true she's considering it
she's processing right now she's like do
i want to show people how to twerk
oh i mean it's all it's easy oh
here we go so you can do the literal
throwback
you bend over like it's the first time
on the simulation
boom first time on submissions holy holy
[ __ ]
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
we're undergoing a twerk session now and
then you just like
move your thighs back and forth can i do
this yeah yeah yeah
holy [ __ ] okay wait wait so number one
is you kind of wait you know you got to
move them um
in and out while your feet are planted
that like does a little something
in and out the throwback okay so that's
one is the throwback
it's called the throwback yeah it's the
probe
and the number two is called the jiggle
oh yeah you know wiggling
wiggling wiggling yeah wiggling the
throwback
so i was doing the throwback right yeah
you were doing it you were kind of doing
this for me i was trying to do this
but yeah i don't have enough of a dunk
dunk
it helps if you do have a dunkin dog but
it is still possible
even if you don't even if you don't you
just gotta feel like the
like gravitational waves of your body
yeah and then you lift when it goes down
and then it just creates
it just does its own thing i feel like
um you got this i feel like we're gonna
try again
yeah we're gonna do this one more time
okay
okay so we're gonna feel the
gravitational waves
okay you got this see okay
this is called just moving you have to
feel something like
jiggle i have to feel like something
jiggles okay yeah jiggling hold on
you're going for there you go
okay we're trying to figure this out
we're trying
well this is yeah this is something this
is great
this shit's hard maybe yeah then maybe i
don't know how good i would be
as a talent doggy style
[Laughter]
or the other position is a cowgirl oh
that's another position where it's like
useful you know
those are like the two useful positions
for it
yeah yeah that's true yeah right yeah of
course are there
are there other positions that i'm
missing well i guess it could be
it could be good it's good in a lot of
other sexual positions it's just that
you kind of have to have
the lift yeah so that there's the space
to do the movement
mm-hmm yeah yeah yeah no it's just good
to have in general uh
also you know it just it probably helps
your pelvic floor to some degree
actually that's a really beneficial one
because yeah actually when i
that's funny when i go out in the
mornings and like do stretches or during
the day
like that's one of the best ways to
unlock like your lower back and your
hips
but i'm like doing it in a very like
like my way has my way has not much to
do with twerking
i'm just kind of like you're just
throwing your back out
i'm just kind of like going like you
know like this a little bit and stuff
like that and just kind of like moving
moving it around exactly
yeah yeah that's exactly what you're
doing yeah you're just
doing the mobility exercises yeah the
movement culture
yeah yeah yeah culture
yeah have you heard of that you know
movement culture yet no yeah
good yeah cause that's what i'm all i
love that stuff
that's like the best most simple way to
heal
pain is to you know get actually
yeah just move these things are
literally just chopping away all the
time so to just sort
of like like treat them like
you know that like they're in an actual
like
ocean and
get the actual non-repetitive
rhythm do something that's you know a
little bit
yeah be sensitive to your own
body what um
i'm trying to think of
it's just like there's two types of
twerking it's three types of time
there's one type of yeah
oh my god yeah you heard it here guys
yeah simulation sex education
episode actually okay this kind of leads
us into that
yeah okay we kind of we put that on the
back yeah
yeah first i would like to talk to you
about the clitoris
oh oh yeah yeah actually what about it
yeah exactly so
it's a perfect guess to talk about the
clitoris as well so
first of all number one point about the
clitoris is that
all heterosexual men need to learn how
to stimulate the clitoris
yes point number one also yeah oh oh
sorry also
all um also all lesbian females and or
bisexual
no no i just have a fun fact so yes yes
so i have more fun facts too yeah okay
one quick fun fact i didn't mean to
interrupt i was just got excited it was
just beautiful
so when when um
the when you're like in the womb and
you're forming
and before oh yeah the the penis the cl
the penis comes from the clitoris yeah
no they both start as the very same
thing and then whatever
yeah and like yeah sure okay
the penis like ejects yeah yeah it
ejects out so essentially the penis head
is the clitoris
so compressed the nerve endings are
compressed
yeah this was actually where i was going
to go so take it away yeah so
actually then when you develop what
like in the womb the vagina
okay get out get your hand out of there
the
vagina is what would be equivalent to
your guys's balls so if you're having
sex
with a woman imagine trying to get off
by somebody
purely tugging your balls yeah
that could probably work but you know
what's probably gonna work is putting
your dick in something so that means you
guys need to focus
on the clitoris exactly because it's a
great point
yeah that's uh super super important
point
it's like and guys that are
good also know that
even while penetration is happening
there's a lot of important ways to be
able to stimulate the clitoris at the
same time
but just on a first principled
fundamental level excellent biological
lesson as well
in terms of biological evolution
but then you get to some sort of a
a you have to go through some sort of
like
deeper meditative practice around
clitoral stimulation
cunnilingus if you want to use your
tongue you know
you have to know how to stimulate and
in this case there's a
there's a compression of nerves
because you gotta realize that that
shit's like you know
it's time the clitoris is like the size
of your fingernail
right yeah it's tiny it's like that size
the fingernail size
it's on my face yeah yeah yeah okay
now ow ow yeah
okay but yeah it's tiny and there's so
many nerves
in it like as you i think it's 8 000
nerve endings and then i think there's 4
000
nerve endings in the head of the penis
yeah
and so women are experiencing 2x
more sensual stimulation
which is fascinating and
then in that compressed area as well
so you can like rub all like 8 000
significantly easier especially with
your tongue
it's fantastic when it's nice and
lubricated
you have to know these things
and then you can do some other things
like if you get really good at this
in a sense you can basically like
you can have you can either like
take the woman into a spread eagle
position
where she's like you know all four out
and you're like
you know she's laying out on like the
couch all four out and you're like going
in
and then there's the other one where
like you're laying down on the couch
oh and she [ __ ] your face
which is which is great yeah that's
powerful that's that's
my 20-21 21 that's the power of stepping
in unlocked a concept on mariah's
take your power back ladies and you just
swipe their nose like a credit card
and that's it yeah yeah yeah i'm serious
i'm 100 serious
because there's there's there's not much
that's as awesome as like when you're
laying there
and you're just like and you're just
like taking it
all in of the clitoral stimulation
and she's like grinding her clitoris on
your tongue
at the same time right it's like
twerking yeah on the tongue
of the guy yeah while your clitoris is
exposed yeah
how dope does that sound yeah it's great
it's great i think um with sex in
general that's something for a lot of
females and this was even for me for a
minute like
i didn't even feel like it was that
great
for a while you know and i was like and
i just felt
weird about it and for a long time i say
up until like even
last year and then
i did start to become more like oh i get
it like i get why this is good you know
and that came with
having like different experiences blah
blah blah but
there's a there's also like knowing
yourself too so like
women should definitely explore
themselves a lot
more and it's funny because like my
friend she got me a vibrator like
however many years ago
and then i would tell my other friends
i'm like oh i got this they're like oh i
don't have one like
i don't really want to get one because
like i feel like i just like the real
thing won't be like it's
i'm like no you can't replace humans
like you know what i mean like the
the level of connection you get but i'm
like you should just get one just so you
know for yourself and even then like so
okay clitoral stimulation is really easy
to do but for women a lot of the time
like vaginal stimuli and maybe this is a
lot to say and a podcast that's a great
conversation
it's actually the perfect podcast it's
all about free yourself we actually have
some content on
on mariah
so then also though with um
like everybody understands like okay
clitorals at least women do like
total stimulation is great but a lot of
the time women don't understand their
own vaginal stimulation and then okay
women already have a taboo about
vibrators
they're definitely gonna have a taboo
about dildos so
that's honestly though where i started
to feel like
because i noticed like before i would
orgasm i'd be like i can't do this like
with people you know i'd be like this is
too much so i'd stop myself from doing
it
and yeah yeah and just because it would
be like
like overwhelming but then when i
when i had a dildo then it was like okay
like i've learned to accept this with
myself but also know
how to now in vaginally like make that
feel good for me yeah so then
you know if i have a partner like
whatever i can then be like oh this is
what
feels good and like i understand myself
i'm not giving that power away to like
my partner
yeah you know what i mean so like you're
asking and you're
receiving and you're having a
conversation about what feels best
and you're aware of what feels best
because you tested and
played around with it yeah and like a
lot of women are even afraid to just
explore their body
in that way you know and like
which is there's nothing wrong about it
and i honestly think that
women should because then you know they
wouldn't feel so weird about having
sexual experiences or like so
self-conscious and
you know being self-conscious about your
body within a sexual experience that's a
totally different thing but um there's
like
i just think the narrative with sex and
women just needs to be
more empowering and less like
agreed like not you know it just needs
to be talked about more because
and not even in a way where it's so like
you know in your face about it just so
it's like comfortable and open for
people to
yeah i think this conversation has been
a lot of
comfortable and open and we
are doing it in a way that hopefully
yeah it excites other people to you know
be like hey you know
babe or you know whether it's the guy
talking to the girl the girl talking to
the guy like
you know check out these two talking
super openly
about clitoral stimulation and
and vaginal stimulation and also for
you know for guys you know men need to
you know loosen up a bit yeah like dudes
are like
way too [ __ ] uptight like in so many
ways
yeah like a dude should get a finger in
his ass
every once in a while to loosen up
seriously
he can put a finger in his own ass yeah
and
uh it's completely serious like you know
while you're masturbating
play with your [ __ ]
and see how that feels yeah play with
the piece
it's called the gooch between the balls
and the [ __ ] play with that area
you know uh you know maybe get
a little bit of a vibrator yourself and
begin vibrating around your
balls and gooch and [ __ ] and yeah
and
an [ __ ] and then um if you
and then that'll slowly make you less
and less of a masculine
toxic douche [ __ ] around other guys
because that's what you
are usually when you've never had any
sort of a
an experience that loosens you up
because you're focused on dominance
we were talking about this before we
started but dudes
are very focused on dominance in
a hierarchy women not so much women
have more of a role in biological mates
as a selection they they more select
guys as guys
and and enter into the hierarchy and
then sort themselves out to the top
but when it's based on dominance it's
not
sustainable it usually collapses when
it's based on
competence it's sustainable and
women tend to select men that are more
competent at the tops of hierarchies
rather than dominant
and the same thing's true in chimpanzees
and so
it's good for a guy hypothetically
potentially
to have had homosexual experiences
and in doing so it makes it
like if you've either sucked a dick or
had your dick sucked by a guy or if
you've
either penetrated a guy or have had a
guy penetrate you
that it loosens you up in a sense
to you know you get to become a little
bit more
vulnerable a little bit more emotionally
intelligent a little bit more nunchi a
little bit more
of a ninja and a wizard and you're a
little bit more
you're less likely to just be a force of
just
pure abrasive dominance that is
constantly trying to prove
masculinity over other men no [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that shit's
gay bro i don't [ __ ] put fingers near
my
dick like you can just say like well
maybe that's doesn't sound like it's
interesting for me
and that's completely different than
[ __ ] up gay [ __ ]
so you know there's that and i think
that's a really important thing to
like put a finger in your ass every once
in a while calm down
yeah that was our whole thing just put a
finger in your ass man
yeah next time you find somebody just
getting a little bit too in your face
you know when bars open up again or
something be like hey man just put a
finger in your ass all right there you
go
yeah calmed down a little bit
but yeah i do think the masculinity
thing
is and the way and i just feel for
all men in general because you guys have
a whole another thing you have to break
free from is
that masculinity thing that you guys
have been brought up in and you know
it's subconsciously just shoved into you
like you know masculine men are like at
the top of their game
they just [ __ ] all the women they have
no emotions what's crazy is you guys
have the same amount of emotions as we
do
you guys just feel them far less
it's like and that's insane as somebody
who's an emotional person like me
like you got it's not like you don't
have those emotions you guys do
it's just like you're told to not feel
them you're told to act like they don't
exist like you know
you don't have feelings if you're a guy
and like yeah um
as i said earlier before it's like there
is no right like women have their
menstrual cycle to be like okay
physically
or not like you just know you're
becoming a woman because you have this
very physical thing happen to you you
know you have your period that happens
every month until like you know you're
40 or whatever
uh very grounding yeah very extremely
grounding
and then as a man guy it's like you just
get older and then it's like there's no
right of passage of like you are a man
now so then there's all this proving of
like
i am a mad i'm a man like and as you get
older that
expresses itself in so many weird ways
and
just trying to prove that you're
masculine and a man it just
it ruins relationships it ruins you know
businesses it's
ruined so yeah yeah it ruins
a lot of our collective flourishing when
guys have a tendency as they run
a company to want to
dominate the world in the sense
and it's easier to recognize that i
can't actually dominate
the world because i need the
phytoplankton and the trees
in order for me to breathe
oxygen and those realizations usually
come from when you become very sensitive
to
what breath and when you become
sensitive to that life force
you evolve your consciousness and you
become a lot less
of a tendency to create
the perverse structures that obliterate
our ecologies
that cause mental health issues
like put a couple put a panel like let's
just let's just put it this way what if
there were you know
who knows these experiments put some
women in the
maybe only women no guys on the board of
directors of
like instagram or something and then say
like
that their one goal for 2021 was to
completely reverse
the attention economy so that instead of
having
all of the advertisements that come up
and the whole screen time
perverse incentives that instead they
create
their whole plan was to create some sort
of a business plan for
you know customers that have the um the
wealth and ability
to pay maybe five or ten bucks a month
to use instagram
and then to gain some sort of rich data
visualizations like they literally have
their engineering and design teams like
produce
great data visualizations for the
customers
and so i can see like where are my
beautiful connections in los
angeles what sort of fields are they
interested in all this type of stuff
like rich data visualizations and then
instead of seeing ads come up
on the screen that are hijacking my
psyche
and and creating like a whole panel of
functionalities for me to be able to
choose
at a more a higher granularity and a
more macro level exactly
um how much time that i want to spend
there what i want to see
all this type of stuff um
slowly work our way potentially with who
knows it might be a panel of five women
that are able to
of on the board of directors that are
able to do something like create a re
change like this because maybe there's
more
of the feelings are actually felt and
it's like
yeah actually i [ __ ] hate it when 14
year old girls commit more suicide
because
of the men perverse mental health
incentives that are on the platforms
which is why
there's things that are happening like
the likes that are being
hidden and the like count being hidden
and
all also stuff but it has a lot more to
do with consciousness than we think it
does it has a lot to do with levels
of consciousness still higher levels of
consciousness especially in positions of
leadership
the less likely you are to continue
stupid business models like the
attention economy period
but gender plays an important role
in the process yeah as well sex does i
think
um i think what where it goes wrong is
mostly
and not goes wrong but how it can become
better is through conscious parenting
and parents raising you know
men and that there are plenty of people
that i know that are doing this
you know that have their own children
that are young that are trying to raise
like their sons and their daughters to
be
more conscious of you know like telling
their boys like yes you can
feel feelings and not trying to you know
empower them with masculinity and
you know like boys don't do that and
blah blah blah like
you know i'm really grateful for that
because like you know
having those people raise children that
are like that is ultimately going to
help
with the next generation and then you
know then there's just
the undoing of the people who have
already been
raised and are now adults in the world
it's like they have their own undoings
to do
you know and like luck with females it's
like a different
it's not necessarily like masculinity
there's just other things that we have
to usually
battle within ourselves but with men
it's like there's this whole
i think there's this book called like
under saturn shadow that's all about
how it's written by james hollis but
it's literally about
masculinity and how it's a destructive
force for
men you know and about the undoing of
that and i read it not
i'm not a man but i just read it because
i do
think it's important to be educated
about male psychology you know it's like
a lot of the time you do
hear like you know oh women are so
that we have the underhand with things
and like you know we're always focusing
on making things better for us but then
men do get overlooked in the way of like
yeah
okay well yeah men have been you know
always like in this position of power
and all this and blah blah blah so like
you know we don't have to focus so much
on them but like no you guys have a [ __ ]
ton of mental health stuff that's like
holding you back in a lot of big ways
and so you know i like to be educated on
that
because you know that's also the my
partner in life like i'm a straight
person so like that's gonna be a man
so i'd like to kind of be educated on
like what he would be dealing with you
know what i mean
so like yep that's uh but that book is
really great as far as like
the undoing of male masculinity
yeah conscious parenting is the massive
key like it is it's the most
upstream key because you have to have
parents that
are aware of what self-realization and
self-actualization means
in order for them to actually be able to
pass down similar wisdom to their kids
otherwise their kids are going to fall
into egoic levels of consciousness
because their kid
because their parents are there it's
just the cycle perpetuating itself
and it'll continue perpetuating itself
until someone in the lineage becomes
[ __ ] enlightened
exactly and it's all you know
luckily the like i said i have friends
that are trying to take on like that
conscious parenting
and undo those things uh and
i would like to think that you know
whenever or if ever
like i have a child that i would fall
into that same category but
i do believe like for a big step when
people say like oh having a kid it does
like
you know you're not gonna it's not a
comp it's a huge accomplishment if you
do
yeah like conscious parenting you've
done so much for the world
that's like you've put another human
being out there that just
at least has you know some form of
consciousness with them
in good intention yeah exactly and that
is like a
feat that is it rivals anything else you
know like a massive business whatever
like you've done something good for the
world
by doing that and i think that that's
ultimately like
and some other psychologists that like
i'm into they'll say the same thing
they're like i feel like
like the key to world peace is really
like conscious parenting
yeah and good parenting yeah yeah the
key to world peace is
consciousness especially as we aim to
bring
enlightened levels of consciousness to
children lyanna
moon was a great example when she came
on the show and she had maya when she
was 21 and then
maya's now nine and this like nine year
old
you know kid that has a
fairly elevated level of consciousness
if you watch the episode how to not be a
boring grown-up
that you'd be surprised at how does
a nine-year-old have such levels
of wisdom and love
and radiant joy and like you'd
sort of need to basically
reverse engineer what was the upbringing
and basically if you're going to have
kids
that are in positions of high levels of
of stress
because they haven't had their
you know in this these are these are
like the classic sort of very
simple simple simple simple simple
analogies that sort of help
us understand
what we mean by this
and so here it's you know in high level
perception
you just have a very simple analogy
between a human and a tree and you just
think like
okay if the trees nutrients
aren't there at the root level it's not
going to be able to produce great fruits
same thing is true of a human you have
to have those basic needs be
met at the root level in order for the
human to be able to
self-realize and self-actualize and so
the classical
examples of very especially like egoic
levels of consciousness are that
like if there's no levels of love and if
there's no levels of
the basic needs being met or if the
lineage has a fuckload of trauma that
hasn't been healed
or that if the books that are being
passed
to the child the education's being
passed the child is an education that
is around the self same
dealing tendencies of like the world is
full of filled with corruption you need
to earn money just for yourself
you know that's some stupid [ __ ] and
that's been passed down from your family
and that's going to keep perpetuating
cycles of trauma and nonsense to your
kids
and so it's almost like like we were
saying earlier you just can't
unsubscribe fast enough
from some of the stupid [ __ ] that's come
from the lineage and from the collective
and you can't you know parse fast enough
for signal
and deploy it not only as like a
conscious parent but into your kids
but also to the people in positions of
leadership
around the world they need
more than ever to feel what non-duality
is
like i'm almost to the point where i'm
beginning to
think like what needs to happen
in order to get davos
to
undergo 5mu dmt davos
yeah like literally the world economic
forum meets at davos like
thousands of leaders in the world and
they
and they undergo a very look like
the macro economics of papua new guinea
in the way that the distribution of
their main export to the
you know and like okay cool like we get
that
it's important to have a macro view like
that but have you felt non-duality
before
do you know what it means to feel one
with everything to feel one
with the creator to feel one with god
one with source
one with infinity do you know what that
union is like because if you don't know
what that's like
and you're in a position of power you
need to get the [ __ ] out of that
position of power
or you need to be augmented so that you
feel that and then you can lead from
that position of power
i think that's the most upstream issue
that
civilization faces is that people in
positions of power
are in egoic levels of consciousness and
they're creating all these downstream
self-dealing narcissistic pathological
effects
onto our social fabrics because there's
some sort of a perverse incentive that's
like
i may as well get a fifth yacht it's
like no [ __ ] you're not getting a fifth
yacht
stop put the
500 000 million 2 million whatever
dollars it is
into hiring you know 500 people to
tackle one of the biggest challenges in
the world
what the [ __ ] i've been talking about
this for three years and we're still
like little kids that are like oh the
world is so complex i don't know what to
do
yeah i get it it is complex but you do
know what to do it's
all about consciousness it's all about
the
individual consciousness and it's all
about the collective's
social fabric and sort of what it
what it there it is
because this is just such a this is such
a main key i do you see
do you see um
things from a deeply consciousness
oriented perspective like this because
i almost see it from like a
consciousness only perspective
and then that's the most upstream issue
is egoic levels of consciousness
and the need to enlighten is that how do
you see it
uh i i do think it is a consciousness
thing there was
i can't remember what book this is but
it touches on this it was like an
activist who wrote this book about how
to create change and it was like
you can't you can pass a law but until
you change the consciousness around that
law
people will still find ways to break it
and not you know what i mean and not
go with it so unless like you can
instill all the laws and all the rules
you want to you know try to create
change but if you haven't involved the
consciousness it's not going to actually
be instilled
so it's definitely a total consciousness
thing because
if you like that book even said it's
like you can do
you can do even the things to make the
change but if the people haven't caught
up to that idea or fully accepted that
you know it's
there's going to be things that go
against it anyway
yeah mm-hmm
yeah i i just i just can't get enough of
this topic honestly this
this seriously seems like the most
upstream topic in all of its nuances
that
we're unpacking and it has a lot to do
with freeing yourself because you become
way more free the more enlightened you
become on
here we talked about that a little bit
um towards the beginning of the episode
but like
dude you are just not free when you're
in a state of shame guilt
fear anger you're not free at all and
also what you're doing
is you're trying to draw other people
into your negative states of emotion
and it's horrible it's actually it's
okay
there's no lack everything's perfect
it's true
but it's also true that egoic states of
consciousness
are nasty and they butterfly the
butterfly effect the [ __ ] out of other
people
to you know be pulled down to your nasty
ass acid going states of consciousness
and they suck man they [ __ ] suck
they suck they suck they suck they're
they're
perpetually disrupting
everything that's happening that's
trying to harmonize our
entire planet like like
just like 2016 and 2020
were not examples of enlightened
consciousness trying to figure out how
to lead the planet to prosperity
they were examples of ridiculously
chimpanzee level consciousness that is
insulting
it's anger driven it's it's
trying to pin the other person as
somebody that is
disgusting and negative and horrible and
versus you know just the complete
decentralization of the entire
nonsensical fiat currencies that have
been enslaving
humans for a hundred years now
that are i mean it can keep going off on
this it's just
we know what the solutions are now we've
all read
you know the creature from jekyll island
we've all thought
very intensely about fiat currencies in
the way that they're
perpetually creating asymmetries between
wall street and then being able to
socialize the losses to the masses as we
saw after 2008
and then satoshi nakamoto comes one
month after lehman brother collapses and
creates an incredible push beyond the
edge of what humanity knows
called the bitcoin white paper which
creates a decentralization technologies
that is enlightenment that is
enlightenment you can literally create a
code deployment to the social fabric as
you were saying a law
and like consciousness in a sense
catches up to it because now like
consciousness is catching up to what
decentralization actually means
but there's a lot of people that are
incumbents that are in egoic
consciousness that are saying that you
know no no no no [ __ ] that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] that you know
that's kind of the example that you were
giving a moment ago
but we need more of this we need more of
this to be
actualized in the world deployments of
enlightened levels
of consciousness in positions of
leadership
from a grassroots level deploying
projects that are beyond the edge of
what
he was know it's so beautiful the
creation
but i also i hate hate
but i also love it i love it because i
know it's necessary for the ascension of
the creation
but i also hate it i hate ego i hate
the way that it destroys and creates
suffering but i understand it's a
necessity
necessary functionality of the creation
do you have uh thoughts on what your
favorite
food is
[Music]
my favorite glad you like that
transition i love that transition that's
that's the perfect
thoughts on what what my thoughts are my
favorite food what are your thoughts on
clitoral stimulation
yeah what an even better transition yeah
yeah imagine like
with a guest in a straight jacket though
that would be hilarious
to watch but i can't you know ask
someone that is supposed to be a
chameleon like
yeah i can't like [ __ ] with someone at
that level
exactly yeah although like jim carrey
probably would but whatever
anyway favorite favorite favorite
favorite i like uh
soupy stewie like things okay
oh yeah okay hey soupy stewie thanks
yeah okay soupy stew like i like be i'm
about to make my christmas beef stew
for christmas i make it every year what
what's in it the christmas beef stew
pretty basic
actually but i do put dumplings on top
of it that's something
there's like these like little uh but
it's
it's so [ __ ] good though and i just
bring it wherever i go
so i'm doing that uh i just i love gravy
i like ramen i just like soupy stewie oh
you like soups
stews i just like brought these soupy
stewie things
yeah those are my favorite you like in
taking warm liquid
in oh yeah man soup your gravies like i
love biscuits and gravy i'm
like i love that [ __ ] yeah yeah briskets
and gravy
yeah it's another good one yeah just
dank
comfort food oh southern food i [ __ ]
love
that also kind of falls under like soupy
stewie
yeah gumbo a2 face i love
like all that i lived in louisiana um oh
yeah that's why you really like soupy
and southern comfort foods because that
wasn't like 19 to
18 to how how many years were you there
again i was there three years but also
my dad lived there since i was five
and you were visiting every summer and
christmas yeah yeah yeah
that's why yeah that's why yeah it's
very southern
gumboy soupy soup yeah yeah
stewie oh my god yeah i love that [ __ ]
that's my thoughts
on favorite fruits yeah yeah i'm a huge
fan of
those foods but that's actually the
first time that somebody has said like
very soupy stewie
uh as their favorite category of food so
you're a first you're the first on the
show to say that
specific yeah category which is that's
good it's good to be that
first also we were the first on the show
to like
play four times talk about
clitoris talk about
[Laughter]
yeah break up your content a little bit
we did we licked
let's see oh yeah we did the this uh yes
yeah yeah yeah licks
um what else was there oh we did some
like
beat boxing oh yeah
we we went we stretched from the
metaphysics and consciousness to the
clitoris
c to c consciousness the clitoris yeah c
to c those are two
gotta make that connection yeah yeah
yeah actually this is a really yeah
exactly now this is actually a really
well-rounded uh
conversation yeah unp unparalleled
exactly in the shape of a heart
yeah i love it this has been great and i
think it it all has to do with freeing
yourself
you can't get to these levels of
eccentricity you can't get to these
levels of holism
if you are not 100 absolutely
sovereign and free mm-hmm
no freedom for you yeah no freedom
yeah but what's cool is you get to
decide when you want the freedom to
decide you have free will to decide when
you want freedom
yeah and you'll get also the most
freedom from realizing the true nature
of
who we truly are and so
ask yourself what is the i
why are the two words know thyself
written on the top of the temple of
apollo at delphi it is the most
prominent greek delphic maxim that
exists two words know thyself what the
[ __ ] does that mean
you know that doesn't just mean
self-actualization in your own unique
artistic expression
it means that unity of all being in
existence that oceanic
non-duality that we truly are sentience
as mariah said experiencing
sentience exploring what this creation
is all as one integral as one
integration
of all the experiences
i'm beautiful i've loved it free
yourself
for yourself maybe we wrap with some
more some more play
let us know your thoughts in the
comments below
yeah let us know your thoughts because
uh i'm sure there's
there's a couple of them rate rate is
twerking
everybody uh
all right i have to use the restroom man
okay let's wrap the show okay love you
very much thanks for tuning in rate
allen's twerking rate mariah's twerking
obviously she gets
five stars i get 1.4 and
um we love you very much thanks for
tuning in if you're heterosexual male
get your game up on that clitoris life
amen amen
and levels of consciousness all day
levels of consciousness david hawkins
eat that up eat that up and go and build
the future manifest your dreams into the
world we love you very much
check out mariah's links in the bible
subscribe to her youtube
uh follow her on instagram check out her
stories they're great
she has a lot of great tips and tricks
that she posts on there all the time
it's great stuff and uh same thing with
us
subscribe and like the video comment
below you know all the good stuff share
it
thank you for making it so far be
eccentric
thanks for making this hard be different
be unique
free yourselves we love you very much
thanks for tuning in we'll see you soon
[Music]
all right i got